this looks like garbage perfect
I don't know this is gonna make noise
every time it's autofocuses let's just
try it maybe this video will never see
the light of day it is highly likely
here's a headband does this do anything
look oh okay this just makes me look
like number one fan of my chair Brad
we're choice boy toy boy toy sport or
school transport hi guys my name is
grace Helbig if you didn't know now you
know that was probably already awful and
I won't that was me doing some vocal
warm-ups tonight it's just one of those
nights where everything is getting to me
everything is making me sad or mad or
disappointed in myself I feel Oh preach
a good bit about knowing hate comments
and laughing at them but sometimes they
get to me every slightly negative or
passively negative comment seems extra
sad and maybe the full moon maybe
there's a full not pregnant just
sometimes it's gonna try to like better
myself through some meditation making
myself dinner hang out with friends I'm
sitting here in front of my camera Oh
goose gets it because sometimes you just
need a second to feel about yourself
because then life can continue on it's
like an emotional fart or shart this is
my emotional shart right now I am awful
dive paint on my arms and on my
fingernails because I was trying to
paint outside today a garbage truck full
of Tanks also there's like dirt under my
nails because I was dressed gardening I
got so frustrated from being on my
computer then I had to run outside and
quickly pack dirt on top of other dirt
and I know that you
[ __ ] you there are so many bigger issues
going on the world why are you making a
video about how you hate yourself dumb
one have you ever seen a video on
YouTube - I'm just asking for you to
allow me to indulge myself in hating
myself for a brief moment I don't want
your pity I might have actually brushed
some dirt off I was stressed gardening
so I decided to sit here in front of the
camera and talk about how much I hate
myself let's do it I bought some adidas
leggings the other day that have two
cans on them in desperate to be
interesting hate myself hate myself for
that
- icing on ah hey grace why else do you
hit yourself
great question me because of that actual
interaction lay else do I hate myself
because I don't wear the right color
foundation long have you planned this
out recently I have no idea what color
foundation I should ever be wearing ever
I cut my thumb on a quartz crystal yeah
I want to strangle myself too please
like and subscribe
oh I hate myself Oh No
well redic table because I'm an idiot I
bought three air plants today yeah I
would unsubscribe to a video about it
being national chip and dip day and in
reality was actual national puppy day
how did I let's read some negative
comments TGIF thank grace it's Friday
I'm like 90% sure I may be calling right
isn't this channel.thank rice it's
Friday I don't care with you I get it
it's not because I hate me too I don't
even know how to do fake gang signs oh
you love cheese I've made
the videos on the internet and all of
those hundreds of videos every video I
considered as something Phil likes is
that something Phil does is it something
Phil relates to and I didn't this time
paint myself like TV show hit the skids
and she is the wrong side of 30 she
seems dead behind the I save it be or
how me and you are someone's been paying
a lot of attention to grace helping in
her career you know where else I'm dead
behind the vagina so there's nothing for
you here why are you here my cheeks are
sinking in no you guys all think that
there's something horribly wrong
happening with my body and I'm gonna
give you a very brief update I took two
months off from drinking before and
during book tour when you drink a lot
and you stopped your games of bloating
in your face and body tends to go down
because alcohol is all sugar a body did
things differently than it normally does
honestly I appreciate a lot of your
concern cause it means that you care
however I want you to know everything's
fine you'll be happy to hear them
drinking moderately now oh boy
also I've been using more bronzer and
harsh lighting and also have you seen my
father Internet yay we rock I know I did
not include paper or scissors in my
video oh my god I hate this joke I'm so
old and dumb I only remember subscribing
to this channel did you just wake up
from a coma if I'm the first thing that
you were experiencing post amnesia or a
very traumatic home oh I'm so sorry for
you okay we are at the pinnacle point of
hey time to go thank you guys for
indulging me and honestly I spent some
time reading comments
and they were really really wonderful
and I forget to focus on how lovely so
many of you are and I really appreciate
that so thank you very much things won't
be fun it is for me run out I got to go
before I actually start like enjoying
myself in my own company I don't know I
really I literally just karate-chop my
eyeball with the tags on the leggings ha
ha ha there's so many layers to how
satisfying that was probably for a lot
of you